[Musica]
a
[Applauso]
che bello ascoltare le vostre emozioni e
ascoltare le mie emozioni
nel condividere con voi la mia parte più
intima la parte più fragile non quella
dello scienziato ma quella delle mie
composizioni musicali che ho tenuto per
tanti anni con me nel cassetto più
segreto della mia scrivania e non avevo
voglia che le persone potessero
giudicarle potesse sentirmi separato da
loro per cui vorrei sentirmi in questi
dieci minuti proprio unito a voi come in
un organismo in cui ho bisogno di
condividere queste vibrazioni che so che
oltre a far bene a me potranno risuonare
con i vostri spartiti con i vostri
strumenti musicali con il vostro corpo
questo brano che vi occhio condiviso con
voi racconta dal punto di vista musicale
il momento del concepimento il momento
in cui uno spermatozoo e un ovulo si
incontrano nella pancia di una mamma e
proprio in quell'istante in quella luce
in quel profumo in quel suono nasce una
nuova cellula nasce una nuova vita
pensate che in quel momento così
delicato così difficile da descrivere
soltanto dal punto di vista scientifico
della biologia cellulare arriva un nuovo
spartito sulla terra un nuovo dna che
non c'è mai stato su questa terra e mai
ci sarà ogni volta è successo anche per
noi vi ricordate quando eravate una
cellula nella pancia della vostra mamma
qualcuno si ricorda quando era una
cellula un millesimo di millimetro
tutti siamo stati quell essere vivente
così fragile poi questa cellula è
diventata 248 una pallina di cellule
fino a 50.000 miliardi di cellule noi
siamo un contenitore di 50.000 miliardi
di esseri viventi quando ci spostiamo
tutte queste cellule si spostano con noi
comunicano tra di loro attraverso la
luce il suono danzano dentro di noi
nascono e muoiono in un processo che si
chiama rigenerazione cellulare quindi
ogni giorno miliardi delle nostre
cellule muoiono dobbiamo ricreare una
parte del nostro corpo è molto bello
descrivere questa parte dal punto di
vista scientifico me ne sono occupato
per più di 20 anni all'università nel
dottorato in laboratorio
e molto bello poi integrare questa parte
scientifica con la parte dell'arte la
parte della musica donà e integra quella
parte che nei libri di biologia non c'è
perché studiamo quelle meravigliose
cellule con le membrane tutti gli
organetti ma sono cellule ferme sono
cellule morte quindi ci perdiamo di
vista un po quello che è il movimento
quello che sono le emozioni quello che
l'amore che c'è dentro ognuno dei nostri
corpi da meraviglia proprio da ricreare
con milioni di miliardi di reazione al
secondo armonia equilibrio e salute
all'interno del nostro corpo è un
processo che funziona in modo autonomo
non dobbiamo noi prestare attenzione ma
è un processo che a milioni di anni di
evoluzione e pensate che ogni cellula
per chi non è addetto ai lavori di
biologia ogni cellula allo stesso
libretto d'istruzioni che è stato
fotocopiato lo stesso dna che ci
accompagnerà per tutta la vita andrà a
leggere il capitolo che gli servirà per
passare dall'informazione alla materia
per costruire ad esempio la nostra pelle
altre cellule andranno a leggere le
informazioni che gli serviranno per
costruire le nostre ossa quindi
completamente diversa
altre cellule del sangue altre cellule
del cuore cominceranno a pulsare ogni
cellula andrà leggere il suo capitolo ma
quello che è una notizia nuova della
scienza che appare in copertina nel una
delle riviste più importanti al mondo e
che ultimamente le cellule si è scoperto
grazie una tecnologia nuova di sel
sequencing che possono riscrivere
ritracciare il loro percorso questo
significa che una cellula che sta per
diventare cellule della pelle può
decidere un certo punto dello sviluppo
embrionale di diventare cellule
dell'osso di diventare cellula del cuore
e questa scoperta così importante dal
punto di vista della biologia molecolare
l'ho sentita anche nella mia vita quando
fino a un certo punto fino a 40 anni
pensavo di fare il biologo ricercatore
di nascondere la mia parte artistica
delle mie composizioni della mia musica
invece a 40 anni il mio nuovo manager
che non è più il manager tedesco e
svizzero dell'azienda in cui lavorava ma
che è l'universo non so se qualcun altro
ha lo stesso manager qualcuno lo stesso
manager non ho mai visto in ufficio
insieme si comporta in modo diverso
l'universo è quindi a un certo punto ti
prende e ti sposta in un nuovo percorso
in cui devi unire contemporaneamente le
sue più grandi passioni la biologia
diventa musica e scopri quanta musica
c'è in ognuna delle nostre cellule
ognuna di loro è uno strumento musicale
produce dei suoni udibili ognuna di loro
a delle corde come quelle del pianoforte
che possono essere messe in risonanza e
determinate frequenze
ecco perché quando ascoltiamo la musica
che ha accompagnato l'uomo da sempre da
quando c'è stato l'uomo sulla terra non
c'è stato un momento storico è una
posizione geografica in cui l'uomo non
abbia avuto bisogno della musica e se
n'è occupato della musica era utilizzato
questo strumento soprattutto nei momenti
più difficili
nel momento della nascita e nel momento
della morte quando la scienza arriva
soltanto fino a un certo punto non
riesce a descrivere bene cosa succede
nel momento del concepimento e cosa
succede quando la nostra anima lascia il
nostro corpo quindi in quei momenti così
delicati l'uomo ha deciso da sempre di
farsi accompagnare dalla musica per
questo che vorrei che fosse riportato
valore alla musica anni fa veniva
utilizzato come un rituale quando si
apriva un disco e si ascoltava quel
disco dall'inizio alla fine
insieme a quella autore nel posto
preferito della nostra casa
adesso siamo come nel cibo come nelle
informazioni
siamo sommersi da tantissimi tipi di
musica quindi sbalzano da una parte ad
altre dieci secondi dell'uno e
dell'altra pizzichiamo un po dappertutto
ma perdiamo quel valore che già portato
ad integrarla con la nostra salute
scoprire come la musica sia nata proprio
come uno strumento di salute
perciò nel secondo e ultimo brano che
voglio condividere con voi vorrei che
proprio grazie alla musica riuscissimo a
riscoprire quelli che sono i nostri
talenti
pensateci voi ragazzi giovani
soprattutto all'università quando vado a
fare le mie lezioni e università di
torino chiede a questi giovani di capire
che cos'è che mi fa star bene che cosa
che voglio fare che lavora voglio fare
provate a creare il vostro sogno del
vostro lavoro ideale e per farlo vorrei
dedicarmi questo brano che si intitola
enrichment di come ognuno di noi non è
soltanto nella meraviglia ma è anche
responsabile di portare i propri talenti
sulla terra perché ha ricevuto soltanto
lui quel libretto di istruzioni e
soltanto lui attraverso il corpo può
esprimerlo e creare
meraviglia della sua vita sulla terra
per fare questo secondo brano mi
piacerebbe che vi alzate tutti in piedi
e mettiate la mano sinistra sul cuore
sul vostro cuore sinistra sul cuore e la
mano destra sul cuore del vostro vicino
di sinistra ce la fate dopo pranzo e non
è facile
qui non c'era
da esse ce la fa un biologo ce la fate
toccatevi
ok
dai dai
ce la fate
ok ok fate quello che potete fate quello
che potete
l'importante che tocchiate il vostro
vicino di sinistra ok
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco
[Musica]
[Applauso]